There we go.
Um
where we have env vars and these are
also just like installed by the user.
Now, I'm going to make a couple of
constraints onto our problem just to
make this easier.
I'm going to assume env vars are
completely locked and cannot be Oh, I
cannot
env vars are completely locked and
cannot be modified by I cannot do that.
Env vars are completely locked and
cannot be modified by um
by the end user
at any point during the run time of the
system. We're going to simplify this a
little bit.
Um we'll assume the things that we are
allowed to modify are the files and
where you should be able to install new
things into our system.
Um
Okay, so like the packages and things
like that, like pip packages and things
Okay. Exactly.
Um now that we have our environment
defined, let's talk about what our what
the user is going to tell us. Oops.
The user is likely going to give us some
sort of instructions. Uh so like
instructions.
And this will come in the form of some
text for now. Uh we can talk about
multimodal later, but just to keep it a
little bit easier, we'll uh we'll talk
about just text.
And at some point, what I really want
coming out of this
is effectively a new environment
that somehow has slightly different
files.
Um
Oops, let me Let me make this the wrong
thing.
And then
excel. Okay.
Somehow what I want to do is I want to
take the new I want to take a shot I
want to take a some environment and some
I want to take some environment and some
instructions and spit out a new
environment out of this.
So at the very high level,
what we'll do is figure out how we can
go do this. Now there's a couple of
different problems that we want to go
into this. The first problem is
the user's instructions may not be very
good.
The second problem is I will somehow
want to know exactly which files are
actually relevant over here. So I'll
start writing some of this stuff down.
Uh why is this so ugly?
Um okay.
Uh
cool.
Uh instruc- instructions unclear.
Very hard to write.
Instructions are going to be unclear,
and then also we're going to have to
figure out find the right files.
But let us assume that these two
problems can eventually be solved.
Somehow we can write a different bot
that can go solve these problems.
Even if I have the instructions and I
have all the right files, there's
another problem, which is
generate the right code.
And this last problem ends up in my eyes
being a lot more complicated and harder
than uh or at least being
perceived to be a lot more complicated
and harder than it actually is.
So before we dive really deep into how
to clarify instructions and how to find
the right files, let's focus on the
bottom part of the problem, which is how
we can actually generate the right code
given clear instructions and the right
subset of files involved.
Let's see what we can do to take
advantage of the fact that this is code
and not plain English.
So when I go write this,
there's a there's a couple of different
things we can do, but I'm going to write
some pseudo code over here.
Def uh update file
instructions
stir and then uh files map
stir stir.
Let's talk about what pseudo code for
this kind of problem would end up
looking like.
The first thing we could do is we could
just ask the LLM to regenerate the whole
file. That is probably not going to be
very effective just because eventually
we all have files that are more than
4,000 tokens long or 8,000 tokens long.
So we just know off the bat that that
won't work for any sophisticated system.
So let's break this out into smaller
things. What we'll do is we'll have it
generate diffs of some kind.
Uh generate diffs
uh instructions
files.
And the reason that I'm jumping straight
to diffs and not even talking about why
to generate files is again because it
can't actually be solved. It's not
possible given the output token limits
of the models today to really solve the
constraint around this problem. And yes,
I know I can run a while loop on the
models and let it keep generating more
tokens.
But at least in my experience, the code
bases are a little bit too complex to
have it go do that. Diffs seem a little
bit more tractable and naturally
compressing the information I need to
just what I need.
Now what I can do is for diff in diff
or maybe I should do this.
Apply diff
diffs files.
And somehow I should be able to generate
new files by then applying the diffs.
And once I apply the diffs, I want to
somehow run some validation.
Validate
uh
validate where I'm going to pass in
instructions
new files.
Oops.
Files.
Uh and then have some sort of result out
of this.
And what I might want to do is more
along the lines of this. While true,
And I'll
this is kind of breaking down the core
of just bag of tools into some kind of
more smaller deterministic glue between
some really focused small things we can
write as really focused small prompts.
Exactly. And the real reason that we
want to go do this is because if I go
look at what generate diffs can do, this
itself could be a whole agentic loop on
its own, and we'll go talk about this.
How you apply the diffs could or could
not be an LLM.
Um and then the actual result itself is
likely not going to be an LLM because at
some point we want to probably run some
code to determine if it's good or bad.
So let's go talk about how we could
apply the diffs
to our system. And then I think the last
thing I'm going to go do is
Let's talk about how we can generate the
diffs. So when I go into the diff
generation, I think the easiest way to
talk about this is actually write
writing some code.
So I have some code over here.
Uh where did it go?
And
Dash, you want to give them a quick walk
through on what this code is that I'm
sharing?
Uh yeah, yeah, I think you should pull
the latest though. Uh I think there's
like an extra file in there.
you go.
Uh so there's not much here right now.
Um so we've got some kind of like base
So we have a project on the on the left
which is just a
small little like calculator
application. It's like a
CLI that can uh run thing run uh
run basic calculations. Uh I showed it
to Vaibhav. He said it sucks. I was like
perfect. Let's get the agent uh let's
have the agent make it better.
Uh I actually agree. This is a terrible
implementation of a calculator. I think
Claude wrote this.
So yeah, if you want to do math, uh you
have seven steps to add 5 + 2.
Uh so this is the program the example
program that we'll have our agent code
up and make better and we'll improve the
uh the kind of UX of this thing. But um
and then in this this other folder in
agent, we have kind of a scaffolding out
of um a small AI application.
Um the only thing that's already written
here is just code to walk a directory
tree and give us kind of a dictionary of
file name to file contents.
Yep.
Um so let's start off with the first
part. Let's generate a diff.
Now you've all probably seen functions
that generate diffs before, but I'm
going to show like two or three
different options on how to generate
diffs because they can make a huge
difference, and especially if we have um
especially the minute you start going to
smaller models, it can really really
dramatically change the quality of your
results as we go talk about this. And I
think that's going to be a very
interesting part about this. So generate
diff.
What we're going to have is instructions
string
and then what we'll have is like code.
And for now we'll pass in only a single
file. We won't pass in more than one
file at once. We'll ask it to generate a
So that's like the current code, the
current state of the file basically,
right?
Exactly. Uh I'll call it I'll call it
something better. Current code.
And what I want to output is some code.
Uh
Let's use GPT-4 over now and I'll bump
myself down.
Um
instructions, here's the current code.
And then what I will do is I will
probably do this. dot roll user
cuz we're using OpenAI's models, they
send to they send to like system
instructions with roll users, and then
we'll add another part of it, which is
going to be
file path.
Um No, I don't need file path. Okay,
let's just add current code.
Okay, let's open this, and then I'm
going to start pasting in some test
cases really fast.
Okay, uh
and when I go ahead and actually get the
calculator, let's grab this calculator
code just so I can test it.
Mhm.
Okay. Now I have something I can go test
really fast that is
doing interesting things
with the calculator.
Oh man, this is so this is so clean.
What instructions are you going to give
it? So what I think I'm going to do is
I'm going to say let's say I want to add
exponent
uh capability on the on the
go.
operator
So it's a pretty clear instruction. The
code is pretty clear and it's pretty
self-constrained as to exactly what it
should go do.
And I probably want to go ahead and
figure out what I can go do and I don't
know what this do.
I don't even know what this is.
Uh and then it's going to go add add
multiply divide. So it will have to
touch multiple files in the system.
But we'll go see exactly what we can do
if we can go add the exponent operations
to the calculator.
If I go run this, it will probably go do
something.
Um
And the first part that I will get is
it's not going to really go to do in the
right way. It's going to offer like uh
giant update system in a way that isn't
very useful. So let's make it actually
better at this.
Uh class this
Uh what we'll do is like we'll say goal
string.
Mhm.
It's just kind of having it outline its
reasoning a little bit before it goes
out into generation.
description And then I'll have it
generate the diff right over here.
Um and I'll say the return type of this
is going to be a diff.
So now what I have Oh, let me do word
wrap.
Now what I have over here is I have a
method that can go ahead and return some
sort of goal and then diff back to me.
Oh, probably don't want to call this
goal. I'll call it like update
description.
Cool.
So it kind of did a diff, but it did it
in a format that is
kind of useful, not super useful.
Um because I can't actually be
guaranteed that any of this is going to
be abided by because I didn't give it a
way to read the diff.
So let's add a little bit more
constraints onto this. Wait, I didn't I
didn't quite follow that. Um cuz I saw
that my first impression was like, "Oh,
that's a diff. That's a patch file I can
go apply to my project right away." So
what's what's missing from this? So the
first thing that's really missing from
this for me is a couple of things.
Yeah.
Um and the first one is really just the
fact that like calculator_original.py is
probably not the name of my file.
Right?
I see. Okay.
Uh calculator_updated.py is not the name
of the output file.
There's these small nuances and I think
these nuances are dramatically going to
change how we parse and go read things
around it.
But
Okay. what I do see is that this thing
probably wants to know what it is going
to go do. So let's give it like a file
path file name in general.
Okay. Real quick by the way, there was a
question about like which part of this
is in the user pro user message versus
system prompt um if you want to clarify
that.
doing right now is everything above this
for GPT-4o is generally going to by
default being the system message,
instructions that the user gives me, and
the output format I want. And the actual
code goes into the user message. I'm
basically treating the instructions of
the user as good as a
uh as good as um
instructions that I gave on the team. Uh
as someone uh on our code wrote. Even
though it's user incoming message, I
treat it like a system message.
So let's talk about like
like what is it like a lot of them all
models have better instruction following
for what you put in the system prompt,
right?
Why not put the current code in the user
prompt?
Um
Oh, why why put the current code? So
there's a couple of different reasons of
why we put this in the current why we
put this in the current code as opposed
to the user prompt. And the biggest
reason is just like the way the models
are oriented. So let's just take a look
at what what this does. If I were to go
were to go read the prompt
you can view like the you can view these
role semantics as basically just like
automatic um oops
I should fix that.
As automatic um
breakers for where the code actually
lives. So now if I were to go write
this, it isn't actually obvious where
the section of my code begins or doesn't
begin. I'd have to add some prefix like
uh code here.
But if I'm using user
I see. system messages, I kind of get
that by default because these are
special tokens that the model ingest
that let it know that it's eliminating
something by default.
Okay, so you're you're not really
relying on the assistant user tuning in
terms of like a chat conversation, but
you're just using switching the user
mode as a really really well-tuned
separator between whatever came before
whatever's coming next.
Exactly.
Cool. Cuz the model is well-tuned to
understand this and this gives me a
really really free way to go paste this
down.
Um Yeah, I think it's he's saying like
basically like if you if you used XML
tags around it, that would be similar.
We're just using this for the purpose of
separating. Yeah, and like we can go do
this and like this
we can do this even now, but it we
really don't need to
because this is pretty well understood
in terms of what the errors they could
have are.
Cool.
Sorry, you were talking about diffs.
Let's Let's go back to diffs. Now, I do
like the update descriptions. I think
these descriptions could be a little bit
better. So like uh let's just rename
this to update notes. And right now I'm
just updating it directly
uh rather than changing like alias or
anything because I'm just I I'm not
really using this code anywhere. And now
let's talk about diffs. Now, a couple of
Okay. So
return in
this format. Let's give it a more
constrained format.
diff
And then what I want is I'm going to
make it generate the diff in a markdown
file.
And I'm going to try and look like this
diff as much as possible cuz this seems
to be the thing the model likes to do.
Yeah, Gabe. Great uh great question.
Yeah, so we're going to start with
GPT-4o and then um we're going to show
how we can use some prompt techniques to
make this work really well even with 4o
mini or something.
There we go. So I'm going to let it go
do this
uh in this example.
Where the way that it's going to
generate the diff is I want it to tell
me what file it's removing, what file
it's adding. And then it's going to put
in some like line numbers or something
around this, I guess. And then
surrounding code, add the deleted code,
add the added code, and give me back
surrounding code at the very end.
Um and it added the closing XML marks by
default. So it didn't really work. So I
updated so it's not a closing tag.
Now, this clearly looks like it could be
misinterpreted. So I'm going to I'm
going to write it like this just to like
make it a little bit more clear that's
not XML or something by default.
So let's try running this now.
Um
Return this format. Don't need quotes.
So escape this.
So let's go read this code and see what
actually pulled out.
So it did actually do something pretty
nice for me whereas it gave me a diff.
It said these lines changed.
And then it gave me another diff where
it says these lines changed. And it told
me exactly what I need to add remove and
add uh this format.
Which is kind of interesting because it
actually was able to detect that the
divide needed a comma and then it added
the exponent.
Mhm. So this seems to work pretty well
in terms of what it's parsing and what
it's returning back to me.
Um Looks like it did still have the
backticks though. Were you trying to get
rid of those? Yeah, let me see uh return
this format. Use
So I told it not to do something as we
saw like my prompt said don't need to
add quotes to escape this. Instead of a
don't, let's add this. Let's Let's give
it a capability instead of removing a
capability. Use triple backticks
to
Do you want triple backticks though?
Like aren't you going to just going to
strip those out later? characters.
So I'll show you what I mean.
Okay.
Let's see if I can get to do this.
Yeah.
Uh
Let's call this field something else.
And this is kind of like a version of
few-shot sampling, I guess you could
say.
That's trying to produce some good code
here. Let's try and run this. Funny, we
have syntax highlighting broken.
Did it go do it? No, it's still adding
the triple backticks. So it sounds like
I can go do this.
Um
So you're telling it to use backticks?
Let me tell you why I'm trying to use
triple backticks.
So the problem is if I don't use triple
backticks, it's going to put the thing
in quotes. If I put it in quotes, it's
going to be really hard for me to find
out where this quotes start and stop cuz
my code itself has quotation marks in
it.
So when I generate the diff, it's going
to break eventually because if it
doesn't the quotes correctly or do
something else correctly, it's
definitely going to go break. So, maybe
what I need to do is I need to call this
diff update diff.
Let it code. Let's call this updated
code.
And then try something here again.
Use triple backticks to prevent escape
characters.
There we go.
So, it's what it looked like is naming
it diff over here was confusing the
model.
But, now that I'm using a name that's a
little bit more unique and specifically
not related to the actual thing I'm cuz
I'm overloading the word diff to mean
too many things. It's both the name of
my output and the action that I want it
to go do.
So, by renaming it to update code, it's
probably a just a little bit easier for
the model to go understand what's going
on.
Um
escape characters uh
and no quotes.
Let's try this one more time see if I
can get something good.
Um nope, the other way was necessary.
Okay.
Oops, there we go. Okay, so this is
actually a a sort of like um
an intuition you have about specifically
about how the YAML parser is pulling
things out of this field. Well, it's
also just about what I need the model to
go do. I do not want the model to
generate worry about these quotes cuz it
will mess up cuz I'm generating large
sequences of code.
Oh, because it's trying to make JSON and
those triple quotes are going to like
make it think that it accidentally made
invalid JSON or something.
Exactly. Got you.
And that's going to be really really
hard thing for me to go get. And the raw
output of the
uh prompt looks like this.
Thanks, someone else.
Yeah, so that context that output format
ends up translating into this this is
like the full raw prompt. And I'm
noticing like answering JSON the schema,
I'll just get rid of that really fast
because this is so finicky.
Prefix
equals
Um and then why is that outputting JSON
so Let me go update this. Okay, so your
concern is that it's trying to escape
all the quotes in the JSON and the
concern is that if the model has to
think about that, then it's going to
kind of gum up and take attention away
from the core task, which is generating
good code. Exactly. So, let's add a
couple more things. Let's add
temperature zero to my system.
Let's run this one more time and see
what it does.
Um
and let's try this one more time.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to
actually move this out of the
description and just try seeing if I can
give it a few-shot example right over
here.
Allow
for no
escape characters.
And now the prompt looks like this.
I see. So, you took the description out
of the actual schema and you're just
adding this as a standalone instruction.
Exactly. So, allow for Oh, I know what
it To allow for multi-
line strings.
There we go.
And now we have it working. I see. Okay,
so you And this comes after the thing
that I think I've heard you say a lot
before, which is this idea of like let
the model write code in the way that
it's most trained to write code, which
is not code inside a big JSON object,
but is just stream the code out flat as
as it as an actual file. And so, by
telling it to use triple backticks, the
model thinks, "Oh, now I don't have to
deal with escape characters. I can just
do this as multi- multi-line string."
Exactly. Exactly. And one quick thing to
note here is I told it to a multi-line
string and you saw me iterate in many
different ways. I wrote a lot of nots in
the before.
And really what I was able to nail nail
down here is by getting rid of all the
nots and really thinking hard about what
I was trying to get it to do, which was
really just like I wanted to output
multi-line strings.
By letting it go do that,
it can now understand exactly what it's
going trying to go do a lot better.
Right, cuz it hasn't been trained on
generating code inside a JSON object.
It's been trained on generating code as
a flat thing. Exactly. And like it's
really about the not concept that is
hard to go wrap my head around,
especially the minute I go to like the
smaller models. So, let's use like a
smaller model like this one.
Temperature 0.1.
Let's just boil this down and see if it
does approximately the right thing.
The idea of a not is just very very hard
for it to go do. And now you can notice
that the diff has gone a little bit
longer because of the slightly smaller
model.
And if I'm doing this, the first worry
that I have is, "Oh, is the model just
outputting like a lot more code than it
needs to?" Let's see if I can trim that
down.
One easy way to trim that down is to
just make it return multiple diffs
instead of one diff.
Cool.
Right? So, let's just go do that.
Oh, it's outputting a lot more code.
Uh let's add some instructions.
Keep diffs
small and
and use multiple diffs.
I wonder if this thing is messing it up
right now
because it's actually telling me that
this allow Technically, the diff format
allows for multiple things to be
included. Let's get rid of this.
Uh Are you going to be able to what Keep
going. I have questions. I'm going to
Let's let's hear this example.
Okay, let's run this.
Um this did not add any pluses or
minuses and we'll talk about this in a
little bit later. And let's go add one
more thing.
I actually change this to be update
notes just to be um a string
instead of a multi-line string cuz
what's likely happening is writing
multiple diffs
and then it's going to head and just um
not really understanding what it needs
to go do. So, what we should really do
is class
So, here's what I'm going to do. I'm
going to let notes be multiple and for
each one of these notes, I want it to
generate one code sample.
Um and then this will return multiple
multiple and then I do not need this
anymore.
And one more try.
What What's the prompt look like now?
There we go.
But, here's what the prompt looks like
now.
Let's go read this fast. Um
So, what we really want to go do is what
we want to go do is we want to say that
we're going to generate a triple
backtick string for multi-line files.
We're going to literally let it generate
the code. Then we're going to say you
can actually generate multiple diffs in
this format.
Uh and then we're going to keep the
diffs small, use multiple diffs for the
same file.
What the model ends up generating is
something actually very useful, which is
add exponentiation operation to the
calculator and this is GPT-4 mini.
And actually it was able to break it
down to say my file, it says, "I need to
go add exponentiate over here and I need
to go ahead and add exponentiate down
here."
Now, the thing that's missing it looks
like is the at symbols actually helped
it quite a lot.
It also added an exponentiate function
directly into this method instead of
adding it to the import.
Um let's go ahead and add a little bit
more context onto here.
Do you want to tell it what file name
we're changing as one of the parameters?
That's kind of what I was thinking as
well.
Cuz it seems like it's getting uh
confused by this.
And that's probably good enough.
So, let me know if that
file name calculator.py.
So, let's read the prompt one more time.
We have the file calculator.py, we have
the actual contents of the file.
And then what we really have is
uh let's run this code in one more time.
I just want to let you know we're at
about 20 minutes left, so I'm um not
sure if when you want to you want to
switch to actually like applying these
diffs.
Cool. That's a good point. Or kind of
the other stages of the pipeline. Let's
talk about the next stage of the
pipeline. So, we have something that
seems to be able to generate some amount
of code from here. And we then we also
have something that can also apply
diffs.
So, now let's talk about the next part,
which is actually generating diffs. I
think we had one last question, which is
how much does indentation matter in the
description in the prompt?
Um indentation pretty much just matters
because it's just like noise.
For example, if I were to not indent
this versus indent this, it probably
just reads slightly differently.
You want to show the token view?
Um can we see if it changes the actual
like tokens? It I mean, indentation is
white space, but like in the end what it
really it doesn't really matter too
much. And the reason it doesn't matter
too much is
the way I look at this is like
think about like a human reading it for
clarity. If I indent this, then the real
benefit that I get as a human is I can
really quickly jump down here and see if
this is where it ends.
Mhm.
The model can also pick up on patterns
while reading this sort of thing, and it
should be able to detect that this thing
it just belongs to the thing above it
because it's indented.
So, in reality, I should probably be
like tapping these in as well, just
because it's just like easier for it to
see like, oh, this is like one
one indentation and this is two
indentations.
Cuz there are tokens that exist for like
four four space tokens.
So, it just like it reads two tokens as,
oh, it probably belongs to a diff inside
of this array. It probably belongs to a
diff inside of this array.
And then I'm going to go back to the
photo.
And now I want to talk about the next
part, which I think a lot of people
overlook, which is how can I actually go
ahead and apply this diff?
Because once you start applying the
diff,
the hardest thing that most people run
into is actually going to be
I'm going to go back to here, which is
when we go out and apply this diff and
we have a bunch of diffs,
most people are like, I'll just go and
like string replace, go do this. But
actually, the best way to think about
this problem is on a per file basis.
So, instead of viewing this as a massive
um
as a I'm going to apply all the diffs at
once, what I'm going to do is I'm going
to apply a single diff
at one point at a time. So, there's
going to be a diff object,
and this will be all and this will be
only that one file that it really
touches.
And I want to go think about this
problem.
The first thing you have to do in this
problem is you have to go ahead and say
find match
And this is going to be like some find
match function of the old method of the
file and then like the current version
of the file.
And if you failed to find a match,
there's a couple of things you can go
do.
You can toss it to another LLM
to go ahead and see if you can find a
match. You can use something like uh
Levenshtein distance or something else
to see if there's something
approximately close to the match.
But in reality, if you failed to find a
complete match, then this whole thing
that it generated at the top is probably
not very useful, even if if you can't
toss it to an if another LLM is unable
to find another match for you.
Yeah, I've seen I've seen cloud code
mess this up a lot, and I I think
there's this not like plus minus diffing
and it's a little bit more like
string to replace So, they do it with
like a find replace basically, and then
it if it can't find the string to
replace, it'll fall back to trying to
use like said and grep. Yeah. So, if you
remember, there was this thing that we
we talked about a couple sessions ago,
which is about managing the context and
like the case of like an error system
where like um
when I'm generating like a Cypher query,
uh I'm going to have the user generate
some context, and at some point the
model will get it wrong.
Well, then what I will end up doing is
when the model gets it wrong, I will add
some new context on top of it. I will
let the model go generate a new
response, and then it will probably
hopefully get it right at this point.
And for my final context window, what I
end up doing is I say
I will literally just ignore everything
that the model did in the middle and
only give the right query.
Oops, I'll change the colors on here so
it's a little bit more clear.
And only give it the right query and
delete these other two contexts out of
it.
So, I'm basically just managing the
context. I'm pretending like I got the
answer on the right on the first try.
I can go do the same thing with a diff
system,
which is once I find a match in here,
uh whether it's by using an LLM, whether
it's by using like a string match,
Levenshtein distance, or anything else
onto here, I'll I'll do my best to find
a match. If I failed to find a match, I
have to abort out of the loop
and leave and go back.
But once I find a match,
then I can do a couple of different
things, which is I can apply the match.
And this is a basic operation to just do
like a string replace.
And once I'm able to go ahead and apply
the match, I can do the next part of the
system, which I think
is the part that most people never do,
which is leverage the AST.
What does that mean?
Well, there's two parts of code that
needs to be correct when I go generate
this.
One of the parts of code that needs to
be correct when I go generate this is
going to be that the syntax of the code
is actually correct.
I can I can use the AST library
uh uh Python provides to go validate the
file itself. And it's not actually going
to make sure that all my imports are
correct or anything else, but what it
can do is just validate the actual
syntax that the LLM generated in the new
diff is correct. So, for example, if it
missed a comma or something else. And I
can find exactly what line has the AST
mistake,
and I can do put this in a while loop.
Okay, so this isn't going to catch
issues with like imports that are broken
or methods from other files that are
called wrong, but at least we'll know
that the code was syntactically correct.
Exactly. Cuz I want to scope down the
problem as much as possible because if
I'm going to go use
um if I'm going to go use something like
um
like code generation, I don't want to
have the model worry about everything
always all at once.
If I can have guarantee like what
guarantee do I provide at the first
sentence? I provide a guarantee that the
match of the old diff exists in some
shape or form matching the existing file
somehow.
And it doesn't matter that I use an LLM
or string replace inside of this method
to go find that exact line.
All that matters is that I was able to
find it.
And when I apply the match, this is a
string replace. I don't have to think
about it. But what I wanted to go do
here is I want to make sure that
um
Okay, so you have another LLM with a
very specific prompt that is like, hey,
here was the change you tried to make,
here was the original goal, here were
the errors. Exactly.
And generate a new diff basically.
I may not even need to give it
uh I may not even need to give it
uh
what
they called the original file.
Since it's just a purely syntactical
error approach.
What's nice about this
like
validate it again or something.
What's nice about this method is that
this fix error method
I'm going to try drawing a curvy arrow.
The fix error method could really be a
thing.
Ooh, I tried. Uh could really be a thing
that goes back to my update files with
just a single file with a very specific
instruction that I have hardcoded to
help it analyze the errors.
So, it could technically go back into my
rebel loop
and that I'm building out here and have
it go generate this.
And it could be like a version of this
method that doesn't actually need to go
run in terms of like um in terms of run
the code. It just needs to go make it
syntactically valid.
So, rather than the errors, you would
actually have kind of like some kind of
new instructions here. Exactly. And
you're kind of recursively you're
recursing. And then what's the exit
condition of this while loop? Is it
like, you know,
if not errors, break?
Yeah, exactly.
Cool.
That's exactly it.
Cool. And I can do something a little
bit more sophisticated where like if I
have like 50 errors or like 20 if like
I've done this loop like five times, I
break anyway.
Yeah. Um but this kind of gets me there
kind of most of the way there. And this
is the same thing. I generate a diff, I
go apply the diff, and I run this in a
loop.
It's pretty similar, but it's defined
it's breaking down the problem in a way
where the only goal of the thing when
the only goal of the update file when it
enters from the fix errors context
is to just fix these errors.
Cool. Following. Yeah, this is uh this
is starting to feel like a an ambitious
topic to try to cover in an hour, but um
I think this is super interesting. The
next thing that we really want to go do
is actually find all the imports. And
again, we can leverage the AST
to go do this.
So, we don't actually have to use an LLM
to go do this. I mean, we could, but we
can also just use the AST in the Python
library to tell us what are all the
imports that are imported into this
file.
And any new imports that are done,
we can just
import them.
It turns out that this is a pretty
straightforward task as long as you have
all imports provided to you. So, if you
see any files that are local files, we
can know the difference between those
because we can detect which are local
files because we have access to all the
source code.
And we can just update the environment
to import everything uh
relative here.
If we run into any errors,
we do the same thing over here.
Uh now, this one gets a little bit more
um sophisticated in terms of how you
would have to deal with these kinds of
errors.
And the reason for that is there's a
couple of different types of errors that
we can imagine that the system has.
One of the types of errors that the
system could end up having
is the fact that
stuff just doesn't exist. It's a made-up
repository.
In that case, there's no amount of
install steps that we could go do to go
fix this and we have to go back up to
here and abort out of the system and
somehow add some new observations into
here that says do not use this library.
The next type of error that we could
really have is the fact that we just
installed something incorrectly in a
slightly different way. Like for
example, one common mistake I make is I
do pip install dot and
where you have to do pip install python
dash dot and.
Mhm. And fixing that sort of error may
require some other like there's a couple
of different ways to go um inspect into
that. One of them is you use like a web
search agent to go and call it and say
how could I fix this error?
One is you go ahead and just like
ask the LM how to go fix the error.
And there's different approaches here,
but in general you can do this.
Why not both? You can do both.
It's just a matter of time and
expediency that you really have to think
about when you build these systems.
Um
fix errors.
Fix install errors um and I've also like
fixed
uh AST errors.
Uh errors and then we're going to give
it actually the file and we're going to
do a new thing in here that we probably
have to think about that I forgot to
include in here which is
uh you want to have some sort of
observations object that you're kind of
tracking over time that you're going to
pass into this.
The observations object needs to be a
thing that is passed into every other
object downstream.
That you can somehow modify in some way
and then go ahead and update as well. So
in this case you might need to go ahead
and update the observations.
There we go. And then you kind of just
want to abort out of this.
Raise
stop exception.
And then
on this method
try
catch. I can't write to the code very
fast.
Uh and I want to abort out of this loop
and really just add some unfixable
errors down here.
But the whole
I think the whole point of what I really
wanted to cover today is that when
you're trying to go build like a diffing
agent the way most people apply this
agent is a very simple loop of ask the
LM to go fix something, if it breaks,
give it the error and go build that loop
forever.
And when you're trying to go do that
system,
the problem with that is you run into a
lot of brittle edge cases that the model
just cannot fix.
And specifically what you're running
into is the same problem that we usually
talk about which is context management.
Which is if you're not manually building
the context up out of the system
it is very very hard for you to navigate
and get the model to go output it
correctly. For example,
maybe GPT-5 or 4.1 can go do this in one
shot for a lot of problems. But GPT-4O
mini cannot go do this very well. It
will just struggle to apply a diff. And
it will struggle to
perfect it.
ability to actually just like understand
full context when it especially as that
context window gets longer with more and
different kinds of errors. Um
yeah you lose you kind of lose the
thread and you spin out, right?
Exactly. So the whole point when we
talked about like the side protection
generation where we're actually able to
remove these two messages out of the
context window and not have to have them
long term and we only keep them around
temporarily becomes even more important
when you're doing a complex task like
code generation.
And the most important part to do is be
able to decompose the problem to very
small problems
and then say all I have to do is find a
match. Cool. I will take the diff. If I
can find the exact string match, I'll go
do it. If I can't, I'll use an LM to
find the line of code that's referring
to.
And if none of that works
then I'll literally just abort and add
an observation to my system and then
have it go do this. And at some point
when it gets to a good state I want to
go ahead and clear the observations.
Cuz they're no longer interesting to the
like next set of problems that we're
solving or the next step back plan.
Exactly.
And it's kind of me tracking this
history over time. And then what I
really want to do is I want to go
leverage existing tools that are really
good for doing certain kinds of tasks.
Like the LM should not to be doing
syntax validation.
I likely also shouldn't be using an LM
to look at the whole file and tell me
here's all the errors go go find out
what they are and go fix them.
If I instead use an AST to tell me this,
then I can give it the exact pinpoint of
surrounding code and say go fix the
syntax.
Yeah, I think Jonathan that's exactly
right. And like the LM's job is to turn
context into new tokens, new code. Your
job of everything else is to get exactly
the right most optimal context into the
LM so it can do that as well as possible
as cheaply as possible. Exactly. And
then same with installs. Instead of
asking instead of running the code and
telling me what I need to install, I can
just find
all the imports. So like for example,
there's a
there's a python library in here that
you can use.
It's called like
import
AST.
Def find find imports.
Uh code.
You can literally just call AST.parse.
And you can literally just walk through
this tree and find everything that's a
module of AST import.
And it will literally just tell you
exactly what this node is.
And it will actually yield out exact all
the all the imports for you.
You can get import from as well.
Um
and I believe this will do everything
for you.
Now this won't catch every import cuz it
will miss out on some of the most like
edge casey imports that you have.
But you can still detect most of them
from here.
Um now the other thing and I can run
this code if people are curious. The
other thing that you're able to go do is
I could also go generate this um yeah I
can also go generate this from actual
code as well.
Function find imports.
Um let's just go write this. Test.
Oops.
If I give it the same code that I have
down below
Oops.
If I give it
Should be LM parse out all the imports.
And then I can just find LM parse out
all the imports. Um
And it will probably respond fine.
And it says the only import is
operations.
Which if I look at the code is actually
true.
it will pull it out. And the beauty of
this thing is there's like this art to
kind of figure out what kind of model
you want to go use for these kinds of
things.
If I were someone what I would want to
do is I'd want to figure out the
smallest model that I can use for each
task.
And in this case finding imports is a
pretty small task so I could probably
throw GPT-4O mini at it. I could
probably throw like a deep sequel or
even like I don't know. Probably like
something.
Like maybe even like a llama
8B.
Oh, that's pretty good.
If you put it out, I think I have llama
uh latest.
I think I have a llama running.
I do not.
Um I can start
know if you need the latest tag, do you?
Uh llama PS. O LS.
O llama LS.
Do I have any of these?
Yeah, you kind of do need the latest
tag. It's kind of annoying.
Uh do you want latest?
Uh
V1.
Um I'll figure out why. I'm probably
missing some
really parameter here.
Um
so I'm going to go do that.
But really determining what model you
have to go use can make a huge
difference. So in this case what I
really want is if I all I want to do is
find imports and I don't want to write
the AST code over here
I can literally just use O llama to go
leverage instead because I know this is
a small enough task. And if 90% of my
system that I'm that I'm writing over
here
ends up using mostly a small small
model, but then some of it ends up using
like let's say GPT-4O, I can get a lot
of value
just by reducing the amount of cost that
I have to go do in in terms of latency
and in terms of accuracy.
Because the most important part I want
to do the hard part as much as possible
with a big model. I want to do this I
want to do the small parts
uh with smaller models.
Um and because when I'm going to go run
this
I run into this problem where like
generate diffs, especially if I'm on day
zero of my system, I do not want to go
ahead and like get all of this down
in terms of the cost and accuracy. I
just want the accuracy to be high and I
don't care about cost. I'll throw this
at GPT-4o.
And because I've spent more time on on
applied diffs, more of this will be
smaller models. And what you do is you
incrementally replace parts of your
pipeline with smaller and smaller
models. And as you add smaller models,
the real work around to make smaller
models better is one some of the prompt
engineering stuff that you end up doing.
But the real thing is really about like
adding supporting systems around them.
So you can actually go ahead and make
them better. So in this case, leveraging
the AST allows me to use a smaller model
because the goal of the smaller model is
no longer generate perfect code and fix
all of your errors. The goal is generate
something that's pretty close to correct
and be able to fix syntactical errors.
It doesn't have to fix logical errors.
It only has to fix syntactical errors.
And then when I go to validate, I live
in this world where I'm again validating
large running code.
And I might have even something detect
what kind of error this is. If it's a
simple error, I'll toss it at a smaller
model. If it's a more complex error,
I'll toss it at GPT-4o or 4.1.
And
And so you're just constantly adding new
probes and knobs and dials on your
pipeline that you can make changes and
you can swap out a bigger slightly
bigger model slightly smaller model etc.
Exactly. And in the end all of this is
really about a distribution play, right?
We have a distri- oops.
How do I draw a line?
Uh
up here. Yeah. Draw a line. Okay. All I
really want is I want a distribution
where the majority of my users fall
under this and I have some long tail of
this and where this is like dollars
going up higher.
I just want I want to make sure that
most of my users fall under this domain.
If like 5% of my users are extremely
expensive, that doesn't really matter
for most use cases. If 5% is really
slow, it doesn't really matter. It is
going to be really really hard for
someone to build an AI pipeline that
looks like this
while having good accuracy. That's just
not the way AI pipelines can work
because of the nature of problems that
users will constantly ask you to go do.
So one way to deal with this, especially
when your problem is very very expansive
like generating code, is you design your
pipeline from the very beginning to kind
of follow this sort of distribution.
And the whole point is your pipeline Oh,
how do I make this thinner? I hate this.
Okay.
Your pipeline starts off at a
distribution that looks like this. It's
very expensive. Right. You're using big
model. This is like what you keep the
kind of the recurring point is like
start with a big model that can do a
bunch of things pretty well and then
slowly over time like as you say, oh,
this is worth building. This is
valuable. We want to invest more
engineering time on this. You're
constantly shifting that code that that
curve to the left and making it kind of
better.
Exactly. So like what I what I can do by
swapping just applied diff section cuz
applied diff is almost definitely the
most expensive part of my pipeline cuz
that's where it's going to make
mistakes. I have to re-correct them and
I have to loop in that forever. It's
probably not in generating diff. It's
probably in applied diff.
By shifting applied diff to be better, I
probably just shift my pipeline to the
whole very much to the left.
And then eventually what I can do is I
can work on generating things that are
really really good for Python and maybe
even fine-tune a tiny model for that and
slowly just over time shift my pipeline
over. But this is the whole point of
where you move your pipeline over is all
about
moving it to the left and adding
engineering over here. What we're really
doing is we're applying engineering to
make it cheaper, faster, more accurate
by taking a better control of the
system.
Does that describe the high-level thing
of what we were trying to do in today's
conversation? It was a It was pretty
ambitious, I guess, to take all of this
and go implement all of this from
scratch.
Yeah, there's a lot of requests for
people want to get working code for all
of this. So maybe maybe we'll have a
hack day this weekend and
Yeah. Yeah, we'll go do that. We'll go
to hack day and we'll give you like
working code from this sample and get
this out. Um no, this is good and I I I
think what's also like what what wasn't
explicitly mentioned but is really
really important to keep in mind is like
every single one of these techniques
that is like, oh, cool. We'll take a big
model and then we'll make it cheaper,
smaller, faster, better. You could take
all of those techniques and just drop in
a big model again and suddenly because
you're doing these accuracy techniques,
your big model is going to perform a lot
better than just a naively single shot
single prompted big model.
Yeah. Exactly. Exactly.
I think what we should really do, Dax,
is we should take this code and actually
just turn this into real code cuz I
don't think I could have pseudo coded
and written the code in real time.
Yeah. Are we going to build an AI to
clone this weekend? I'm doing a I'm
doing a hack day on Friday, dude. Maybe
we'll have you join remote. Yeah. We'll
go do that. So we'll probably send out
an email slightly later with today's
session with the working code. Uh expect
it probably around the weekend.
Um are there questions that people have?
I know there were a couple that were
asked as we were going on.
Yeah, feel free to come off mute mute
and shout and tell us what you liked or
what was confusing still or drop it in
the chat. Hey hey Vaibhav. Hey Dax.
Thanks thanks for the great session. Um
so this
this was super great for the problem of,
you know, making targeted changes in
code. I'm curious if you guys have any
thoughts of, you know, how how how the
problem kind of changes when we're
thinking of, you know, building
something from scratch, right? So like
if I were to go to, you know, StackBlitz
or V0 or whatever, I just I want to get
a whole bunch right off the initial
prompt. How do you guys think about that
that problem?
I view that as a totally separate
problem as updating existing code. So if
I were building a system that were going
to go do this, and again, it's all about
like this left-to-right movement, Yep.
the way I'd move this system from left
to right,
uh
the way I'd move this system from left
to right is I'd first build a system
uh that is able to like I'd build two
separate systems like generate new code
and
update existing code.
And really just build a router between
them
that decides which one I'm going to. And
I'd treat them as two totally totally
separate systems.
Um and that's why V0 is so freaking good
at giving you a UI out of the box, but
it's so bad at updating code eventually
because at least what I run into is like
I get amazing draft one. Chat message
one, beautiful. Chat message two,
amazing. Chat message like 25, I'm like,
oh my god, I'm ripping my hair out
trying to get it to do the thing I
wanted to go do.
Because it's just not as um
it's just not as precise.
And it's just this balance that you end
up having to go do for now given today's
models. Does that answer your question,
Tal?
Yeah, I I I guess I'm I'm curious how
you how feasible you think it is for
something like V0, maybe like what what
the time and this is a you know, a very
loaded question like what the time frame
might be where something like that could
be commoditized.
think I think a lot of getting this
working is actually not about getting it
working but also giving people really
good tools. So V0 has started to go do
this. But one of the things that you'll
notice like Cursor do, so like I'm in my
I'm in my I'm in my Rust code base,
is Cursor will actually let me like
refer to actual code right in here.
Yep. And the reason they do that is
because it turns out this problem that I
saw at the very beginning of finding the
right context is really really really
hard.
I get a lot of value by the user just
telling me what they want me to pass in.
So instead of having to build this out
directly from scratch, V0 likely has to
build some sort of tooling to make this
better. So I'll show you some of the
tooling that they've built out that I
think is headed in this direction and
shows this point very directly.
So like um
I'll just open this floating bubbles,
whatever.
Right? Um and look at what they can do
here. They actually allow you to now
select these elements very directly and
apply quick changes. Why are they doing
that?
Because if you don't do this, you will
not generate good code. Like they cannot
do it.
So a lot of these paradigms in terms of
generating perfect responses will not
just require
uh not just require like code changes
foundationally at the very bottom layer,
but they also require UX workflows that
are
tuned perfectly to the exact way that
you are currently writing that code.
V0's case means point to that part of
the element. Cursor's case means refer
to that file. So if you are building a
competitor, then what I would do is I
would figure out what is the
what is the most UX friendly way for the
person to give you the right context?
Cuz if you have the right context and
you have good instructions, it is really
easy to go do that.
Good instructions are a lot easier to
correct using a model and ask clarifying
questions. Bad context is virtually
impossible
to correct. So just help the user give
you the right piece of code.
Does that answer Yeah, that's Yeah,
that's that's awesome. I didn't know I
didn't know that was in V0. I I have
used V0 from time to time. I do think
browser tools
has that as well. I have I have used
that functionality with the browser
tools MCP via Cursor. So if anyone's
using Cursor, they may want to check
that out, too. But thanks.
Um I don't know if there's a hand
raising. I just wanted to say thank you.
I love the V0. I'm using it more. Um I
do a planning and task operation first
and I tell V0 to write in a documents
folder. It will create documents,
scripts, everything else. I'll do up to
20 planning and documentation steps
before it actually starts to instantiate
and write code. What I actually give it
is a full PRD with a front end spec that
I write outside. I've been able to
generate up to like 200 files, half of
which are docs and half of which are
code with like uh
like 11 different directories with only
just a few errors in the final initial
page generation, just as an FYI. With
the right planning and having it write
to its system and read it.
in a week.
Yeah, from what I've seen I'm pretty
sure V0 is doing something special with
import and stuff because they see with
import detection like just from relative
files.
Because that's like the easiest way to
go fix this and like given how technical
the Next.js team is in TypeScript
specifically, they have a really easy
way to showcase some of these errors and
go fix these bugs.
I just want to say thanks. This is my
second session with you. I'm new to
Vercel.
And absolutely brilliant everything I
can. Thanks so much for today. Thanks,
Derek. Awesome. Love it. Thanks for
bringing your energy.
Yeah. Um other questions from anyone
else that's left on?
Cool. Um in that case, we'll call it a
good day today. Um and then Dex and I
will send out working code for this
uh on the calculator repo.
Hey, you you committed it. That's on
recording. I mean, yeah, it's recorded.
It's going to happen. Um
it's never hurts to write code.
It'll be really fun.
All right. Thank you, everyone. And
thank you again, Dex. This was really
fun.
Yep. And last, thanks, everybody.
See you guys in the next week.
Catch you all later.
Bye-bye. Thanks, Dex. See you.
See you.